[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente chers collègues
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie
depuis une semaine c'est le festival des
promesses creuses pour répondre à la
colère des agriculteurs il vous demande
de les protéger des importations à pris
cassé mais depuis 25 ans l'Europe avec
la France multiplie les accords de libre
échange avec un but gagner des marchés
pour les grands groupes de l'industrie
et des services en décimant
l'agriculture française depuis 7 ans le
président Macron finit de sacrifier les
agriculteurs il a ratifié un accord avec
le Japon Singapour le Vietnam le Chili
Nouvelle-Zélande et il soutient les
accords avec le mercosour l'Australie
l'Inde l'Indonésie la Thaïlande et
pendant que vous y êtes vous allez
peut-être nous ressortir le tafta alors
vous nous dites pas d'inquiétude
j'engage un bras de fer avec Bruxelles
en endormant les éleveurs français avec
des closes miroirs ça ne vous dérange
donc pas d'avoir des dizaines de
milliers de tonnes de viandes importées
en plus d'Australie ou du Brésil qui
viennent d'élevage de dizaines de
milliers de bêtes où le coup du foncier
est presque nul qui passe par des
abattoirs géants où le SMIC n'existe pas
close miroir ou pas c'est une
concurrence insoutenable pour les
éleveurs que vous imposez c'est vrai
aussi pour la pêche les fruits les
légumes comment osez-vous faire croire
que vous protégez l'exception agricole
française ça fait des semaines que le
président Macron nous répète que la
France a mis fin aux négociations avec
le Mercosur c'est faux le vice-président
de la Commission européenne dombrovski
le rappelle hier les négociations se se
poursuivent comme prévu monsieur le
ministre stop notre agriculture se meurt
de votre folie dérégulatrice une autre
agriculture est possible à condition de
la protéger des multinationales et de la
concurrence internationale vous devez
convoquer un conseil européen retirer le
mandat de la France des négociations de
tous les accords de libre échange en
cours à commencé par le mercosour oui ou
non le
ferezv je vous remercie ma ch collègue
la parole est à Monsieur brune le ma
ministre de l'économie et des finances M
la présidente mesames et Messieurs les
Députés madame les député trouvé tout
d'un coup la France insoumise découvre
qu'il y a des paysans en
[Musique]
France après avoir proposé des
augmentations de taxes des augmentations
d'impôt des durcisss de règles des
durciss de normes vous VZ des paysans et
des agriculteurs il n'est jamais trop
tard pour bien faire s'agissant du
Mercosur madame trouvé je vous rappelle
qu'il n'y a qu'un seul État en Europe
par la voix du président de la
République qui s'oppose à la signature
en l'état de l'accord mercosure c'est la
France et c'est le président de la
République nous avons réussi à bloquer
ces négociations parce que nous estimons
que cet accord en l'état est injuste
qu'il mettrait nos éleveurs dans une
difficulté insoutenable et qui n'est pas
question de laisser rentrer sur le sol
européen des dizaines de milliers de
tonnes de bétail qui ne respectent pas
les mêmes normes et les mêmes règles que
celles que nous imposons à nos éleveurs
et à nos producteurs enfin je rappelle
madame trouvé que c'est grâce au
président de la République et la
négociation qu'il a mené avec le
gouvernement chinois que nous pouvons
exporter des ports de Bretagne et que le
kilo de port de Bretagne son prix
augmenté parce que nous pouvons
l'exporter vers la Chine je rappelle que
notre balance commerciale a vult augment
parce que nous pouvons exporter plus de
vin vers le Japon et je rappelle que nos
producteurs de lait sont bien contents
de pouvoir exporter 50 % de fromage de
plus vers le Canada parce que nous avons
signé un accord de libre échange avec le
Canada ne tuez pas l'agriculture
française avec vos mauvaises idées
madame la
députée je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre